Wow I'm gonna start this video by
telling you there will be no spoilers no
hints nothing so you're safe with me
two braids directed by JJ Abrams of Star
Trek and Mission Impossible three Fame
and produced by Steven Spielberg it's
about a group of kids who are really
into moviemaking they're making movies
in 1979 they're using a super 8 camera
there's a train wreck and something
escapes this train some thing and I'm
gonna get into what it is the super 8
camera is filming this event this thing
starts wreaking havoc in the city and
there's all kinds of confusion about
what it is and these kids they have this
personal drama dealing with a few issues
I don't want to get into honestly you
experience that yourself so it's like a
coming-of-age story for these kids who
kind of have to man up they're aware of
what's going on but you know no one
believes that I had towards super 8 I
just I loved it it reminded me so much
of me as a kid from like our early teens
my friends and I have run around making
weird little creature movies with our
cameras something in the woods
and so I related to these kids so much
because nothing was gonna get in the way
of finishing that movie I was gonna
cause so much problems for my friends
and everything and just I had to finish
the movie it was so accurate to how kids
are when they get a camera and they
realized what they can do with it it was
really cool because the film takes place
in a small town in Ohio I live in Ohio
there's also a really great scene
involving a gas station when that's all
I'm gonna say but as I'm driving home we
had to get gas and there we saw a gas
station in the middle of this rural area
with like these this forest all around
us and it was like so much like the gas
station in the movie I was getting
creeped out this is just a movie made by
film fans for film fans obviously lots
of inspiration from ET here Close
Encounters of the Third Kind Michael
Giacchino's score is terrific I've seen
all JJ Abrams films and this is by far
his best he's really rising as one of
the best directors working today the
film looks so good it's so suspenseful
and JJ
he knows how to keep you guessing about
the entity in this film he's not just
gonna like throw it in your face you
know he's gonna he's gonna like hint dad
you'll get a little shadows and things
it's just it's great that's that's how
you do you don't show it all as soon as
it's there because then you lose all the
suspense great directors like Alfred
Hitchcock knew that you don't just show
whatever is supposed to be scared you
hold back because the audience's
imagination will create whatever they
think is the most frightening and that's
why the thing in this film works so well
the performances from the cast all
around are excellent Kyle Chandler as
great as the police officer all the kids
are just great this is some of the best
young acting I have seen in years
this film is such a wonderful tribute to
the kind of stuff that Spielberg created
in the 80s that made kids excited about
being kids but the thing is my mom saw
with me I took her to the screening
she's 60 and she loved it it will appeal
to all different types of ages may I
mention this movie is hilarious it's
just so funny this movie has everything
thrills
fun great special effects just it's just
fantastic and the film has such a
wonderful emotional vibe to it a
relationship between this young boy and
the young girl is so sweet as the film
draws to a close it's just so touching I
loved it
actually my favorite movie of the year
so far I flipped out over this movie I
really hope you all loved it as much as
I did I'm gonna give it 4 out of 4 stars
as a side note my second blog is up on
the schmoes no comm website please check
it out when you get a chance super it
comes out on Friday oh my word it's good
Oh
[Music]